[موسيقى]
عفوا
كنت أشك في نفسي
أننا سنطرح هذا السؤال
لأكون صادقًا جدًا معك
تحدثنا مع صباح اليوم
الشركة التي تنظم رحلاتنا
تحاول معرفة ما إذا كنا لا نستطيع
التحرك في يخت رملي
[موسيقى]
التي سأخبركم بها عن نكتة
صدر الذوق السيئ أمس
حتى لو كنت أحب الدعابة و
هذا مهم بالنسبة لي
الفكاهة لكني أدركت ذلك
في النهاية كانت مزحة سيئة
تذوق في موضوع حساس للغاية وأنا
بالنظر إلى النسب التي اتخذتها
أول شيء سأخبرك به
نحن هنا في باريس سان جيرمان لسنا بالخارج
أرض
أن النادي ككل
لاعبين فريق عمل الجميع جدا
من الواضح الالتفات إلى مشكلة
المناخ وذلك تحت أي ظرف من الظروف
في أي حال من الأحوال نفعل أي شيء لدي
من الواضح أن سمعت الكثير
بين مكالمات امس
من الواضح اليوم حتى لو كان لدي
حاول الاستمرار في التركيز على اللعبة
لا داعي للاعتذار
نكتة سيئة الذوق
لكن صدقوني في النادي في النادي
نتأثر جميعًا بهذه المشاكل
المناخ هنا